[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates the
100 million dollar whistleblower former
Swiss banker Bradley Birkenfeld living a
life of luxury after cashing this check
from the US Treasury I have a very good
life and rightfully so he blew the
whistle on thousands of Americans hiding
their money in numbered Swiss bank
accounts and now he's ready with another
bombshell the names of several prominent
Americans who have not yet been publicly
identified so are there still more
explosive details to come out from UBS
you think just because you're not
indicted doesn't mean you didn't break
the law plus law day as the country's
highest ranking lawyer is on the hot
seat they have not asked me to open an
investigation perhaps they've suggested
I don't know I wouldn't say suggested
inferred you don't know now a group of
prominent lawyers asking what happened
to the rule of law and our shout out to
the reporter whose stories on the mayor
of Baltimore led to a full federal
investigation $800,000 to the mayor for
a children's book full of misspellings
in educational children's book about
eating right she spelled vegetable rock
from the law and crime network this is
Brian Ross investigates good evening and
welcome tonight we're at a place which
might be called and investigated a
reporter's dream a gathering of people
who investigate financial crimes and the
whistleblowers who help them a place
where this man is a rockstar Bradley
Birkenfeld the whistleblower who has now
been paid more than 100 million dollars
for blowing the whistle on Americans who
had secret bank accounts in Switzerland
after taxes the amount in this US
Treasury check made out to Brooklyn Feld
was some 75 million dollars the most
ever paid to any whistleblower it sent a
message to the rest of the world and
other potential was
that if you have the courage you can't
come forward to make a change
now Birkenfeld an American citizen is
rich beyond his dreams with homes on the
island of Malta on a lake in Italy and
in London all thanks to a US law to give
whistleblowers a percentage of what they
help to bring in you're living in pretty
good life I have a very good life and
rightfully so because what I did was I
followed the IRS whistleblowing law and
I help them build a program that really
needed this a lot of people would say
you have too much money or we never
should have paid this but what they
don't understand is is what I did was I
put a illegal business out of business
and birkenthal told me he's preparing
yet another bombshell the names of
several extremely prominent Americans
who Birkenfeld says had numbered Swiss
accounts but have not yet been publicly
identity so are there still more
explosive details to come out from UBS
you think oh sure absolutely just
because you're not indicted doesn't mean
you didn't break the law at the time he
decided to blow the whistle Birkenfeld
says he was making two million dollars a
year at the UBS bank in Geneva already
living a life of luxury as he helped
wealthy Americans hide their money in
numbered accounts we had 19 thousand
accounts and 20 billion dollars in
assets Americans just Americans and
these were Americans with essentially
secret accounts not paying taxes not
disclosing that they had these accounts
to the IRS that is correct I mean these
were undeclared numbered accounts in
which they were hiding their money from
just the tax authority but also as they
said a spouse or business partner and so
forth so this was going on for quite a
long time but again that was just he
counts you also had homes yachts cars
safe deposit boxes which weren't
accountable so I felt as though I
couldn't sit sit still and be quiet and
I always say silence is complicity but
you are part of the scheme aren't you
well that's it yeah whistle blows
generally worked within the organization
I was at UPS but I was the only one in
the history of this entire
decades-long tax fraud to come forward
so that should say something alone
when Birkenfeld a mid-level banker with
her confess whistleblowing set off a
worldwide scandal he touched off an
investigation that would threaten one of
the world's largest banks with
extinction and shake 300 years of Swiss
banking secrecy to the foundations of
its underground vaults I think this is
the beginning of the erosion of bank
secrets the world's rich and super-rich
are beginning to pull their thumbs as
the rest of the world starts to attack
Switzerland and it's banking secrecy it
transformed a multi trillion dollar
industry forever after this week's
conference US government officials we're
doing all they could to advertise for
more broken fellas we ended up having
proceeds collected of about 1.4 billion
dollars and out of that was Birkenfeld
and his lawyer Steve curry is it too
much money is it over-the-top absolutely
not the key in a whistleblower program
is to incentivize and motivate people
who are afraid of losing everything and
to get the really big fish the people in
high levels with large amounts of money
I mean who make high salaries you need
large rewards period so are you getting
people to come forward now who are more
than just blow level mid-level employees
after Brad's award there was a
remarkable change you start seeing
people who are chief executive officers
executive yes as whistleblowers
executive vice president's chief
compliance officers chief financial
officers these are people who in the old
days would never have blown the whistle
but under these incentive programs once
they realize they can land on their feet
and they're invaluable information about
major frauds
can actually result not just in change
but in protecting their careers
Stephanie good morning so these are
whistleblowers inside the FAA tell one
impact already being seen this week
reports of a number of whistleblowers
coming forward about what they know
about the production and alleged flaws
of the Boeing 737 max involved in two
fatal air crashes one of the country's
top whistleblower lawyers is Eric Haven
prejudge whether it's going to solve the
mystery of what happened here but it's
always better to have more information
and the people who know this information
are insiders and is that person doing it
for the money absolutely not in fact
they're ambivalent about whether they
even won right now their decision is I
don't even I just want somebody to
listen until recently that was the
motivation of America's best-known
whistleblowers celebrated in the movies
like Karen so clear report against the
nuclear industry good I know what you do
it Jeffrey Wigand who exposed the
tobacco industry the American public
need to know Erin Brockovich taking on a
big gas and electric utility these
people don't dream about being rich they
dream about being able to watch their
kids swim in a pool without worrying
that they'll have to have a hysterectomy
at the age of 20 mark Whitacre the
informant inside the ADM company how can
you possibly stay there when you're just
taking down the company and they need me
to run the company Frank Serpico the
idealistic New York cop guys telling me
take their money we'd feel a lot better
and I said what do I care what you feel
I like to sleep at night and Mark felt
the FBI agent who was the Watergate deep
throat source how long have you been in
the FBI 30 years that's
of information nan got rich like Bradley
Birkenfeld did you do it for the money I
didn't and I think if you look at the
time line you can see that I started my
whistle blowing a year and a half before
the law was even passed so anyone who
says that I had this idea that was for
the money is wrong because I I quit my
job at UBS in Switzerland far before the
law was even past but Birkenfeld paid a
price of all the bankers that you
exposed how many went to jail no one how
about you I was the only one to go to
jail in the whole financial crisis
Birkenfeld was big news on that snowy
day he reported to a federal prison to
serve 30 months after prosecutors
claimed he had not been fully
forthcoming in his whistleblowing and
tried to protect his biggest client the
Bush Department of Justice who was more
interested in indicted a whistleblower
than getting to the facts it's proven I
went to the SEC the IRS the US Senate
and the DOJ and before they even knew me
they were hostile towards me as a
whistleblower
you were angry when you went in there I
still hold the federal judge responsible
I hold the prosecutor responsible
because they know it's a lie I never
should have gone to jail because I was
on exposed this multibillion-dollar
decades-long
tax fraud so the fact that you want to
scapegoat me because it made you look
like a fool
sure that's what happened I was a
scapegoat but it was just two weeks
after Birkenfeld was out of prison on
work release that the IRS sent him that
75 million dollar check and what was
that like when you got that check in
your hands there is a real check right
oh it was a US Treasury check and one of
my attorneys Steve called brought it to
me because I was in New Hampshire at the
time and I had to sign it because he had
to deposit the check so it was quite a
moment which will never forget it I
recall being very vindicated that moment
sitting in this little barn house with
Steve and and we hugged each other so it
was really quite a joyous moment yes did
you go out for a big dinner or buy an
expensive bottle of wine or I was still
on probation so I couldn't drink
but what I did do I the first thing I
bought was I bought a brand new Porsche
Cayenne Turbo so I spent some money on a
new car and it was it was quite a joy
just to be able to know that I could
just buy whatever I wanted and it was a
big change from going from prison to a
barn in New Hampshire and a 75 million
dollar check Birkenfeld has written
about his whistleblowing travails in the
book Lucifer's banker the bookmark is
actually a reproduction of the 75
million dollar US Treasury check he
received in the book he takes on the
federal prosecutors who he dealt with
and who later decided that he should go
to prison
- he's vowing to blow the whistle on
them from the moment I walked in the
hostility was obvious they called me a
tipster not a whistleblower and they
said we don't really believe you have
information and they told me I watched
too much TV that's Hollywood they told
me I didn't know what I was talking
about well then I have a hundred four
million reasons why I'm right they're
wrong so now you're a multi-millionaire
rich beyond your dreams and you're still
on the case though you won't let it go
why not well it's a good question and I
think it's important for people to
understand when you go through such a
roller coaster ride of this magnitude I
have the capability now not only the
funds but I have the knowledge and the
motivation to help other whistleblowers
who are less fortunate than I am and a
lot of them are a lot less fortunate
never got paid got divorced lost their
job and so on and so forth so I'm going
to rectify that what I'm going to do is
go back in and not only continue to
whistle blow against my own government
the Department of Justice who is corrupt
and have to be exposed which I'll
continue to do that but also to help
future whistleblowers to understand that
you can't come forward and Birkenfeld
says he's also pressing now to get a
pardon from President Trump who he says
should understand his plight I think
President Trump if he knew the merits of
my case and they looked at them what I
did as
a historic first for this country I
brought more money back to America than
any American in history I eradicated an
illegal business that was an undermining
our economy and in fact what it's done
is it's exposed as he's always said a
corrupt department of justice and that's
exactly what's happened in my case
have you now applied for a pardon I
haven't applied but I think my story
will get to the president and I think
that's really important for people to
understand the merits of my case are
deserving of a presidential pardon and I
hope the president would recognize that
coming up next the White House
stonewalling the Attorney General on the
hot seat they have not asked me to open
an investigation but perhaps they've
suggested I don't know I wouldn't say
suggested I don't know inferred you
don't know okay prominent lawyers are
asking is American democracy in crisis
when we return
on a week that included what's called
law day the country's highest ranking
lawyer Attorney General William Bar
found himself on the hot seat on Capitol
Hill in an appearance that led some
Democrats to call for his resignation
attorney general bar has the president
or anyone at the White House ever asked
or suggested that you open an
investigation of anyone I wouldn't I
wouldn't yes or no I will repeat it has
the president or anyone at the White
House ever asked or suggested that you
open an investigation of anyone yes or
no please sir the president or anybody
else seems you would remember something
like that and be able to tell us yeah
but I'm trying to grapple with the word
suggest I mean there have been
discussions of matters out there that
they have not asked me to open a
investigation but perhaps they've
suggested I don't know I wouldn't say
suggest hinted I don't know inferred you
don't know okay
overall the actions of the Trump
administration have led a group of some
500 American lawyers to question what
has happened to the rule of law joining
us now from Yale University's School of
Law is visiting lecturer Jean Fidel a
member of the steering committee of
what's called lawyers defending American
democracy thanks for joining us mr.
Fidel is it really so bad that American
democracy has to be defended
unfortunately it does need to be
defended and it's something that the bar
has not been as effective at attending
as we would like to think let me give
you some illustrations we live in an era
in which the president then did it and
let me let me stress at the beginning
this is not a partisan under thicknesses
lawyers from every part of the
profession we live in an era where the
president has labeled the news media as
the enemy of the people basically taking
on one of the core elements of American
democracy
the president has criticized their court
system as broken and unfair he's
vilified an entire Federal Circuit the
US Court of Appeals for the Ninth
Circuit calling it a costly and
dangerous disgrace he's referred to a
federal district judge as a so-called
judge gene let me ask what lawyers do
about that well that's the question and
what we think has to be done is the bar
has to come forward as the bar I'm
talking about the Bar Association's
nationally as well as in every state and
major city where there's a Bar
Association even at the county level the
bar should be coming forward and
standing up for the core principles of
the American legal system it's a fact
that many lawyers that come forward
doing pro bono work representing
individuals in the Muslim banned
litigation that we all remember it's
it's not that long ago the law schools
have created clinics this one here at
Yale Law School and many other schools
have come forward individuals have come
forward but we need to have the bar as
an element of the American legal system
to come forward and and use its vocal
cords get out there and stand up for
core principles that the bar has an
interest in and the bar is uniquely
qualified to speak about this Fadel a
quick question from our control room and
executive producer Rhonda Swartz um you
say it's not a partisan group but won't
this just be perceived as a group of
liberal lawyers beating up on President
Trump well evil is in the eye of the
beholder but I'm here to tell you this
is a nonpartisan these are people from
all over the political spectrum it's a
group that got together actually it
began last fall as a result of a 50th
law school class reunion that I
participate
and it has grown by leaps and bounds we
have people from all over the country we
have players law means law professors we
have people who have been former Jud so
so it's definitely not partisan it's a
part of a group Jean Fidel thank you
very much for joining us today from Yale
University coming up our shout out for
the reporter who broke the story of the
Baltimore Mayor and the FBI
investigation that led today to her
resignation our shout out tonight to the
reporter at The Baltimore Sun followed
up on a Sunday afternoon phone call tip
to break an explosive series on the
city's mayor who resigned today just a
few hours ago the FBI searching the home
and office of embattled Baltimore Mayor
they came out of the house with boxes
and boxes upon evidence when the FBI
raided the home of Baltimore Mayor
Catherine Pugh it wouldn't have been
much of a surprise to the readers of The
Baltimore Sun at its Statehouse reporter
Luke Broadwater who has a good source
and a good nose for when something
smells fishy
and sometimes tips pan out and sometimes
they don't you know you chase and but
this time it resulted in something and
frankly I was personally very surprised
by how how strong and harsh the reaction
was and how quickly things began to
change the tip involved members of the
board of the University of Maryland
Medical Center giving themselves
lucrative deals but the center refused
to answer any of broad waters questions
so that as I like to say set off my
spidey sense and I said well why why do
you want to answer my questions you know
so I started calling around people in
the nose and soon Broadwater with the
help of other reporters documented how
the mayor who was on the board had
received some $800,000 for a series of
children's books
healthy Holi many which were never
distributed or even printed we also know
that thousands of the books are sitting
unread in a warehouse at the school
system headquarters because the school
system says they never asked for the
books and they think they're of not high
enough quality to be used for
instruction so these books just sort of
showed up when the score says school
system's doorstep one day he unasked-for
unsolicited but the books are good for
lots of laughs it seems it is hard to
believe whose books were bought purely
on the base of literary merit reporters
who've read them have pointed out that
for a start she can't seem to settle on
the correct spelling of the name for one
of her main character educational
children's book about eating right she
spell vegetable rock we do know the
mayor had some books in her house and
her car forgot to any kids as saw during
the FBI raid they were carrying out many
of the boxes of the healthy Holly books
before she resigned mayor Pugh had
offered an apology to the people of
Baltimore for anything unethical and
then she launched into a bizarre
three-minute pitch for her new line of
baby clothing for the son it has been a
story no other news outlet has come
close to matching one of those times
when everybody in the newsroom knows
there's a big story so it's sort of an
all-hands-on-deck approach I mean I
think at different points probably maybe
10 or more reporters have had a byline
on this story and serves as yet another
example of the value of robust local
reporting I think like this shows the
Sun with the Sun at its best and what
the Sun can do yeah
[Music]
we've we have covered something that
nobody knew was happening we exposed it
and there's been swift change and
ramifications that would never have
happened
if it were not for a strong local
newspaper
so our shout out tonight to Luke
Broadwater and his colleagues and
editors at The Baltimore Sun following
up on that weekend tip not refusing to
let the story die that's our program for
tonight thanks for joining us we'll see
you again here next week good night